In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 3 on which we commemorate our venerable fathers
Isakias, Dalmatus and Faustus.
On the third of the month we celebrate the memory of our venerable fathers, Isaac, Faustus
and Dalmatus.
The son of a distinguished family, our Holy Father Dalmatus, was a soldier from his youth.
He served as an officer in the second company of palace guards and showed, despite the company
he had to keep, a lively piety.
When Emperor Thildosius was informed that Isaac the Syrian hermit had predicted to valence
his defeat against the Goths and had told him of his miserable death, the sovereign went
to pay him homage, taking Dalmatus with him.
Enchanted by Isaac's angelic mean and his words inspired by the Holy Spirit, Dalmatus
went shortly afterwards to spend seven days with him to enjoy his teaching.
On his return home, his heart inflamed with zeal for God, he told his wife of his decision
to renounce the world.
He gave her all his possessions, sent her back to her family with her daughter, and, taking
with him his infant son Faustus, hurried back to the holy hermit.
During all the honors and feudal cares of the world, he soon became the most eminent
of Isaac's disciples, both by the order he showed in ascetic labors and by his love
of Isihia and compassion for the poor who crowded the monastery.
There he spent an entire length without eating, and, ascension day, having come, he was
born in ecstasy to the church of the Holy Macabees, where the Archbishop was celebrating.
Saint Isaac, having fallen asleep in peace in the year 406, the monks unanimously asked
the Archbishop that Dalmatus take the succession.
Despite his reservations, the saint accepted.
He added to his austerities to make himself worthy of the charge.
He always remained within his monastery, refusing to go out, even when Emperor Thildosios
II urged him to take part in the processions organized in the town to appease God's wrath
at the time of an earthquake.
Through the favor that he had received from God, he acquired the power to discern the secrets
of the heart and to dispense justice.
It was most especially during the period of the Nestorian Heresy that his holiness
shone forth in support of the triumph of the truth.
When Nestorius, before spreading his fraud, was elected Archbishop of Constantinople, he
went to visit the Holy Hermit.
Dalmatus, however, sent him away, saying, first set right what you have hidden in your heart,
and then you can come into my cell.
Once the Prelude had left, Dalmatus said to the monks and layful who were present.
Be wary.
For a vicious beast has come into the town, and will do harm to a great many people.
Nestorius, having revealed his perfidious intentions and heretical opinions concerning the mother
of God, the third Holy Ecumenical Council was conceived in Ephesus on 9 June.
Thanks to the energetic action of Saint Cyril of Alexandria, the Heresy was at once
condemned by the bishops, but Nestorius' adherence strengthened by their ascendancy over
the emperor and the court still hoped to have the council fail, blocking all communication
with the capital.
Saint Cyril succeeded nevertheless in getting a letter to Saint Dalmatus by the hand of a
man disguised as a beggar, who had hidden the misive in a hollow stick.
On reading the letter that the fathers of the council were being threatened by imperial
troops, Dalmatus fell to prayer, and received a command through a heavenly voice to leave
his monastery for the first time in 48 years in order to save the imperiled church, followed
by all his monks who were joined on the way by a crowd of other religious and layfolk, holding
candles in their hands and singing psalms.
The saint was admitted to Emperor Thodosius' presence, who was amazed to see before him
this monk whom he had so often summoned without success.
Dalmatus read the council's letter to him and begged the sovereign to give the bishops their
freedom and to work for the triumph of the truth.
Confirmed of what had actually been happening and enlightened by the saint about Nistorius'
activities, the Emperor sent an edict to Ephesus, commanding that the council's decisions concerning
Nistorius' deposition be ratified and ordered him to retire to his monastery near Antioch.
Leaving the palace, Dalmatus told the people from the Ambon of Saint Mocchio's church of
the contents of the council's letter and gave an account of his meeting with the Emperor.
He then wrote to Saint Cyril in the name of the monastic superiors and eminent men of the
capital to assure him of their unfailing support.
It was after these events which marked a decisive move towards the victory of Orthodoxy that
Saint Dalmatus was made Archimandrite by the council and Exarch of all the monasteries in the
capital, a title inherited by his successors, making the monastery of Dalmatus the first among
the monasteries of the city and the bulwark of Orthodoxy.
Saint Maximian, having governed the church only for a short time, it was during Saint Proclosus
Episcopate that Saint Dalmatus fell asleep in peace at the age of 85 in the year 440.
As soon as the news of his death spread, the whole city hurried to the monastery,
young and old, monks and layfolk, all carrying candles.
The funeral was solemnized by Saint Proclos in the great church,
and then his body was taken back to his monastery.
After three days, a fragrant balm began to flow from the sarcophagus in which the Saint's body
had been placed, and many of those who anointed themselves with it were healed of their ills.
Informed of the saints' last wishes, Archbishop consecrated Dalmatus' son Faustus Abbott
and Archmandrite of all the monasteries.
Refulgent with the grace of the Holy Spirit, wearing a venerable beard which made him look like
Aaron and gifted with the gentleness of Moses, Saint Faustus showed himself not only to be an emulator
of his father's virtues, but also an imitator of his zeal in the defense of the true faith
at the time of the condemnation of Utakis in the year 448, and also an inheritor of his
wonderworking power. After having wisely governed his spiritual flock, he departed to join Isaac
and Dalmatus in the assembly of the saints during the reign of Marcian in the years 450 through 457.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.